on accuse parfois les responsables
politiques d'être hors-sol difficiles de
faire ce reproche à mon invité elle a
connu pas moins de 4 métiers très
différents les uns des autres avant
d'ajouter une dernière ligne à son CV
celle de députés de la majorité
présidentielle
bonjour Brigitte Lisot bonjour Clément
Méric alors vous êtes une députée plutôt
discrète on vous cherchez pas forcément
la lumière sauf que pendant le débat sur
la réforme des retraites on a découvert
une autre Brigitte Lizo vous êtes mise
très en colère quand un député
communiste a reproché à la majorité de
ne rien y connaître au travail on
regarde
en termes de
travail je crois que nous n'avons pas de
au le soir recevoir j'ai commencé à
travailler à 18 ans j'ai eu quatre
métiers différents
j'ai une mère j'ai une mère qui a
commencé à travailler
elle a elle s'est arrêtée à 65 ans si
vous calculez 55 de travail elle a
aujourd'hui 90 ans alors s'il vous plaît
les leçons vous les gardez merci
on sent que cette attaque de
l'opposition elle a touché une corde
sensible en vous ah oui là c'était
vraiment c'est tout ce que je suis en
fait et tout ce que je représente ma
famille c'est la valeur travail est une
valeur essentielle chez moi chez nous et
là ils ont piqué juste là où il ne
fallait pas alors c'est vrai que tout au
long de votre vie vous avez vous avez
enchaîné des métiers très différents les
uns des autres vous avez commencé très
jeune à 18 ans je crois que vous étiez
démonstratrice dans des supermarchés
pour Pernod Ricard Cestas vous avez
ensuite été commercial chez Hachette
visiteuse médicale pour un grand
laboratoire pharmaceutique ensuite vous
avez tenu un restaurant à Lille et enfin
vous avez ouvert une pâtisserie
spécialisée dans les éclairs les éclairs
pas seulement au chocolat qu'est-ce que
ça dit de vous ce parcours professionnel
cette vie de moi que rien n'est
impossible quand on a un peu d'audace et
de courage des opportunités vit aussi
puisque les choses sont venues
progressivement à moi je les ai remarqué
et je me suis engouffré
première fois dans une dans une autre
vie un autre métier il y a aussi l'idée
de relever des défis sortir un peu d'une
zone de confort c'est quelque chose qui
vous plaît ça c'est exactement ça et
puis peut-être aussi éviter la lassitude
à un moment et aller là où on ne
m'attend pas et où je ne pensais pas
aller donc là où on ne vous attendait
pas effectivement c'est la c'est la
politique après c'est mille et une vie
professionnelle vous avez répondu à
l'appel lancé par Emmanuel Macron
appelle à la société civile en 2017 et
vous avez décidé de briguer
l'investiture au législatives à Lille la
politique avant cela elle est occupait
quelle place dans votre vie alors
une conscience politique
de toujours mais la politique pour moi
je la faisais depuis mon canapé avec des
idées très précises et très arrêtées et
en me disant c'est quand même fou que
une telle décision a été prise ils ne
savent pas ce que vivent les etc donc
voyez avec une sensibilité plutôt de
gauche
en marche au législatives à Lille et
face aux vieux routiers de la politique
qui était face à vous et ben vous avez
fait de votre propre inexpérience un
argument de campagne pourquoi vous avez
senti que ça pouvait répondre à une
attente des électeurs parce que c'était
aussi la réalité je n'étais pas une
politique attendue ni formatée en
revanche j'avais mon expérience de vie
pour moi et c'est ça répondait aussi à
une demande à un désir d'Emmanuel Macron
de changer un peu les comportements et
de changer la politique et ça répondait
une attente des gens vous pensez enfin
vous l'avez ressenti pendant la campagne
alors ils étaient un peu déstabilisés
parce que certains se disaient si elle
le fait je peux peut-être aussi le faire
donc et là c'est aussi un message que
j'ai pu envoyer involontairement mais
aussi
inconsciemment aux femmes rien n'est
impossible
et puis il y a aussi d'autres parties
les politiques locaux bien implantées
qui ont vu débarquer une femme pas si
jeune en plus et qui a un peu bousculé
quand même les habitudes et justement
vous êtes versaires comment ça s'est
passé vous ont pris un peu de haut ce
qui a eu des moqueries ou ah oui ça je
peux vous dire que on m'attendait en
ricanant
et puis j'ai donné ce que j'avais à
donner c'est-à-dire moi ma personne
telle que je suis et le résultat a été
effectivement puis j'ai été élu j'ai
largement d'ailleurs j'ai lu que
certains de vos adversaires vous ont
surnommé la vendeuse d'éclairs de l'île
c'est vrai ça c'est possible ou la
pâtissière alors
j'essayais de démentir tout simplement
parce que je ne suis pas pâtissière et
que c'est un métier tout à fait
respectable mais ça n'était pas le cas
mais bon
peu importe vous êtes vous avez été élu
sur cette idée du renouvellement mais
pas seulement c'est aussi sur l'idée de
faire de la politique différemment si on
devait faire le bilan aujourd'hui
quelques années plus tard est-ce que
vous avez vraiment fait la politique
différemment
alors il y a deux de
point de vue il y a le mien et puis
peut-être la politique nationale et vous
personnellement
moi j'ai apporté mon passé de citoyenne
lambda si je veux dire et ça c'est
quelque chose que je n'oublie pas c'est
quelque chose qui vit avec moi et j'ai
encore quelques fois cette réflexe de
dire mais non c'est pas comme ça les
Français ne réagiraient pas comme ça
alors après bon effectivement moi je
suis prise dans un un grand groupe donc
quelquefois les idées que l'on aimait ne
sont pas retenues et puis là j'ai une
certaine loyauté mais là aussi je la
tire de mes expériences profession
Nelles vous savez vous avez dit que
j'étais dans un grand groupe
pharmaceutique effectivement
on
porte le groupe individuellement une
fois élu vos premiers pas à l'Assemblée
ont été un peu compliqués il y a une
journaliste radio qui est venue vous
interroger sur la toute première loi du
quinquennat la loi travail en vous
demandant ce que vous compreniez de
cette réforme et on va voir que votre
réponse a été un peu confuse on a
beaucoup parlé de la version de la
attendez
inversion de
alors pour quelqu'un comme moi qui est
assez
direct qui va vite à l'essentiel
quelquefois je suis un peu perdue des
salles de commission
la version de la
c'est des échanges le texto ouais ça
c'est la boucle telegram alors là c'est
la boucle les députés du Nord bon
écoutez là je trouve plus donc on va
laisser tomber alors votre question
vous dites vous-même que ça a été un
baptême du feu un peu violent et
douloureux vous savez je ne l'ai pas
réécouter depuis un bon moment et je
regarde enfin j'entends ça avec beaucoup
de tendresse en fait alors effectivement
je ne suis pas une un grand tribun je
veux pas dire tribune
de langue de bois on est d'accord et il
y a aussi alors je vais pas passer trop
de temps sur ce sujet mais aussi un
contexte à savoir que on était venu
visiter mon bureau
c'était mes premiers pas de interrogé
comme ça sur tout et la formule était
que je devais moto poser les questions
donc tout ça ça faisait beaucoup de
choses et puis bon voilà c'était un
épisode et vous en avez tiré une leçon
vis-à-vis des médias en général oui
peut-être de la méfiance parce qu'en
fait effectivement là j'étais quand même
un peu piégé c'est un sujet qui a été
diffusé plusieurs mois après
l'enregistrement effectivement au mois
d'octobre
je n'aurais certainement pas répondu de
cette façon là ce qui peut ressortir
aussi de ça c'est que votre inexpérience
a été un atout pendant la campagne
est-ce que ça pas été aussi une
faiblesse dans vos débuts en tant que
député mais là encore je vous dis
c'était les 15 premiers jours
probablement et comme quand on entre
dans un nouveau monde une nouvelle
entreprise il y a des codes que l'on
doit s'approprier c'était peut-être un
peu tôt alors en 2018 vous expliquer que
vous ne faisiez pas partie de ces
députés qui visent un ministère vous
revendiquez même votre absence
d'ambition personnelle pas d'ambition
politique je fais un travail de fourmis
expliquer vous c'est louable mais en
politique est-ce que c'est pas aussi une
erreur que d'être toujours dans l'ombre
est-ce qu'il faut pas à un moment
s'affirmer se montrer pour avoir un peu
de poids dans les débats je crois que
c'est une micro-société le monde
politique et on peut pas tous prendre la
lumière on n'a pas tous ce désir là moi
je ne fais pas partie de ces personnes
là je pourrais aussi encore vous dire
que je n'ai pas d'ambition politique
personnelle je n'attends pas de
ministère ou de secrétariat d'État mais
vous avez quand même l'ambition de
changer les choses mais je suis une
députée de terrain et les choses je les
change même si elle n'apparaissent pas
dans les vidéos Tik Tok même si elle
n'apparaissent pas dans les émissions du
soir
on arrive à changer les choses
en étant une députée de terrain et en
remontant les sujets locaux à
l'Assemblée en 2017 vous avez déclaré je
ne voterai jamais une loi avec laquelle
je ne suis pas d'accord et un an plus
tard les échangements de ton vous
expliquer je n'ai pas toujours été en
adéquation parfaite avec les lois qui
étaient proposées
c'est le métier qui est rentré en
quelque sorte c'est l'apprentissage de
la politique il y a certainement de ça
et encore là je vous dis quand on fait
partie d'un groupe
on y va après il y a toujours cette
possibilité
dans le jargon de l'Assemblée on dit
qu'on a piscine quelquefois donc on est
absent
aussi dans les dans les codes de la
politique à l'ancienne c'est finalement
c'est un peu ça mais d'un autre côté en
fait des lois on en vote assez peu on
vote énormément
au cours d'une session mais des lois il
y en a relativement peu donc on peut
aussi ne pas voter des articles on peut
ne pas voter des amendements et aussi
une forme d'expression au législatives
de 2022 vous pouvez plus jouer la carte
du renouvellement de l'inexpérience vous
étiez plus la vendeuse d'éclair au
chocolat qui se lance en politique vous
étiez la député sortante finalement
l'expérience ça a du bon vous avez joué
la carte de l'expérience à cette
occasion alors j'ai joué la carte de
l'expérience et puis j'ai eu aussi en
retour cette expérience c'est à dire que
je n'étais plus regardée de la même
façon et j'étais vraiment la sortante et
effectivement ça aide beaucoup on va
passer à notre quiz à présent alors
c'est pas compliqué je vous explique le
principe vous allez devoir compléter les
phrases que je vais commencer allez-y on
y va un bon député c'est bon c'est comme
un bon chef pâtissier il doit
il doit mettre la main à la pâte et
respecter
respecter le dosage des ingrédients
aussi on politique oui peut-être et mais
on peut être aussi créatif
à l'Assemblée tout est devenu plus
simple quand j'ai compris que
quand j'ai compris que
on ne jouait pas sa vie à tous les
moments parce que au début vous aviez
peur c'était pas une peur mais c'était
vraiment le rôle de député et très
important pour moi porter par exemple
une écharpe tous ces symboles là ça
pouvait vous paralyser un peu dans votre
dans votre action j'avais un tel respect
une telle image de ce relax ça pouvait
peut-être me déstabiliser enfin demande
à ça va trois mandats
on verra on verra pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas pourquoi pas très bien
on suivra ça merci beaucoup Brigitte
isot d'être venu dans la politique et
moi merci